هذه هي الصور الاوليه لمحطه القطار التي
تعرضت لاعتداء اليوم او تعرض فيها بعض
الركاب لاعتدال وهناك بعض الاصابات التي
لم يفصح عنها الان هذه الصور مشاهدينا هي
صور اوليه من داخل المحطه اذا مشاهدينا
كما افاد مراسل العربيه قبل قليل شرطه
باريس توقيف منفذ الهجوم على محطه قطارات
الشمال الشرطه اطلقت النار على منفذ عمليه
الطعن ونجحت في تحديده وهي ايضا تقيم
حواجز امنيه عندما حطت غاردينار في باريس
بعد عمليه الطعن وهناك عدد من الاصابات في
عمليه الطعام في محطه جاردينار في باريس
نعم حسين يمكنك ان تكمل ما بدات به
خمسه جرحه تصيبوا بجراح طفيفه سقطوا نتيجه
الطعنات التي وجهها اليهم المعتدي بالسلاح
الابيض قبل ان تتمكن الشرطه من اطلاق
النار عليه وتحييده كما اوضح خط مصادر
امنيه اصيب ايضا في الاعتداء
احد سر الشرطه
بطل الحدود تحديدا هذا الجهاز خاص ضمن
الشرطه اصيب بجراحا طفيفه النتيجه
الاعتداء الذي حصل عند السابعه الا كل سن
من صباح اليوم